ein verbrecherischer angriffskrieg war
nötig um dem westen klar zu machen wie
gefährdet er selbst ist das ist alles
andere als theorie der nordatlantik pakt
und die eu müssen spätestens jetzt ein
bekanntes neben zitat beherzigen
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist besser
putin misstrauisch auf die finger zu
schauen wird zur überlebensfrage doch
welche strategie gegenüber russland ist
die richtige die nato umzug ins krieg
aufrüsten stadt einmischen jetzt in der
phoenix runde
wir geben außerdem wieder neue
sanktionen bekannt gegenüber 400
personen und unternehmen in
übereinstimmung mit der eu gegenüber 300
mitglieder der duma gegen oligarchen und
russische rüstungsfirmen die die
kriegsmaschinerie befeuern zusätzlich zu
den 100 tausend us soldaten die derzeit
für die nato in europa stationiert sind
hat die nato vier weitere gefechts
verbände geschaffen die in rumänien
ungarn bulgarien und der slowakei die
ostflanke verstärken sollen
der us präsident joe biden zieht die
schrauben an und damit herzlich
willkommen bei uns meine gäste zunächst
zugeschaltet stefanie babst ist bei uns
ehemalige
stellvertretende beigeordnete
generalsekretärin der nato unter
verschiedenen nato generalsekretär und
seit 2000 20 strategische beraterin und
publizistin professor thomas jäger ist
uns zugeschaltet politikwissenschaftler
lehrstuhlinhaber für internationale
politik und außenpolitik an der
universität zu köln
hier im studio professor johannes farbig
ebenfalls politikwissenschaftler
ebenfalls lehrstuhlinhaber für
internationale beziehungen und
europäische politik an der universität
halle wittenberg und matthew
karnitschnig ist bei uns europa
korrespondent von politiker hier in
berlin stationiert ein ursprünglich aus
den usa stammen des online politisches
online magazin das ist auch in
gedruckter form gibt herr jäger was wir
jetzt gerade von joe biden noch mal
gehört haben was wir gerade
beziehungsweise jetzt den tag über in
brüssel alles erlebt haben wie stark ist
denn die nato im moment nach putins
angriffskrieg und dem heutigen tag mit
all den zusicherungen in brüssel
einen schönen guten abend in die runde
und die antwort ist sehr stark sehr
geeint es ist das gegenteil von dem
eingetreten was bringt sie denn putin
seit langem anstrebt nämlich die nato zu
spalten das war ja sein ursprünglicher
plan die nato sollte in drei
sicherheitszonen und verteilt werden ein
kupfergürtel von puffer staaten in
osteuropa dann west europa und davon
abgetrennt die usa und das gegenteil ist
geschehen
die nato ist zusammengerückt sie hat
ihre abschreckungskräfte aufgebaut und
ist nach meiner einschätzung so geeint
und handlungsfähig wie schon lange nicht
mehr vor papst
der amerikanische präsident hat ja
zusagen gegeben an die nato an die nato
mitgliedsländer in europa gerade auch an
osteuropäischen nato mitgliedsländer
hindert die ja eigentlich kaum noch
zurück an das was da jetzt an
sicherheitsgarantien aus washington
kommt gilt das auch für die zeit
nacharbeiten
eine frage an mich ja das habe ich jetzt
eben nicht ab
die sorge für die zeit nach schon bein
geht das wissen wir nicht aber das ist
eine sehr theoretische frage der
präsident der vereinigten staaten ist
joe biden ergibt diese zusage und das
ist eine gute und richtige zusage sich
als amerikanischer präsident hier voll
an seiner europäischen verbündeten zu
kommen also richtig zu verpflichten was
jetzt die zukunft angeht den in amerika
beginnen vorwahlkampf mit blick auf die
midterm elections im november man wird
sehen wie sich das entwickelt aber ich
habe den eindruck dass der amerikanische
präsident sich sehr sehr voll seiner
verantwortung in dieser dramatischen
existenziellen krise für nicht europa
für die westliche welt für die
demokratische welt bewusst ist
der ukrainische präsident solecki war ja
zugeschaltet zumindest am anfang dieses
nato-gipfels am vormittag was kann die
ukraine den erhoffen von der nato
ja die können glaube ich mehr rückhalt
erwarten vor allem ihr von den
vereinigten staaten es wird ja keine
flugverbotszone
wie sie sich gewünscht haben aber das
glaube ich erwartete er eigentlich nicht
mehr wiederholt also diese
diese biete ja immer wieder aber ich
glaube ihm mittlerweile ist es ja ihrem
klar dass das derzeit nicht infrage
kommt solange putin nicht zu den chemie
waffen oder den atomwaffen greift wird
es dabei bleiben dass man mit
finanzieller unterstützung und auch mit
nachrichtendienstlichen informationen
der ukraine weiterhin hilft und das ist
ja schon etwas bislang geflossen ist
der westen hat sich da die nato staaten
hat sich da untergehakt macht putin
trotzdem so weiter wie bisher
das sieht bisher so aussah jäger hat
natürlich recht die nato ist stark und
geeint und ich denke das ist nicht nur
politisch der fall sondern auch
militärisch der fall die nato ist sehr
viel stärker als russland und ich gehöre
nicht zu denen die annehmen dass putins
plan ist im baltikum in polen zu zünden
sondern er weiß dass das nato
territorium eine andere aus marke als
die ukraine ist aber gleichzeitig ist
die nato auch in gewisser weise teil des
problems weil das natürlich auch darum
russland natürlich auch darum ging ein
nato-beitritt der ukraine zu vermeiden
das heißt es ist eine gemenge lage und
die nato macht jetzt ein bisschen ein
ritt auf der rasierklinge das ist ganz
schwierig aus zu balancieren sich nicht
in diesen krieg involvieren zu lassen
und gleichzeitig zu signalisieren dass
man stark und geschlossen wobei das die
nato mitgliedschaft der ukraine ist ja
unwahrscheinlicher denn je das hat ja
selbst elends die jetzt eingeräumt
richtig aber das war ja teil des
vorspiels dieses krieges gewissermaßen
das ist ganz offenkundig
russisches erklärtes vitales interesse
war das ist ein stoppschild war der
nato-erweiterung wenden wollte und zu
meiner überraschung steht in den
kommunen von heute drin dass die politik
der offenen tür weitergeht ich halte das
für einen schweren fehler der natur
es gibt jetzt meldungen aus der ukraine
nicht nur dass der russische angriff
stock dass es offenbar große
ernüchterung gibt bei den in der
armeeführung und auch bei putin ist an
gewisse wieder geländegewinne um kiew
herum also dass offensichtlich sich
sogar die ukrainische armee
bestimmten stellen richtig behaupten
kann nicht nur abwehrt
wie ist denn die militärische lage im
moment aus russischer sicht wie muss man
sich das vorstellen was geht da in
russland in moskau vor sich
also punkt eins ist ja dass der
ursprüngliche plan der militär
strategische plan nicht aufgegangen ist
also eine relativ zeitlich begrenzte und
auch
fokussierte operation zur entmachtung
der gegenwärtigen ukrainischen regierung
zu starten daraufhin hat der russische
generalstab hat die russische regierung
eine wenn sie so wollen neue adaptierte
strategie jetzt angefangen umzusetzen
und man sieht also dass die russischen
streitkräfte ja nach wie vor
von drei seiten versuchen von drei
geografischen punkten versuchen
strategische geländegewinne zu machen
meine einschätzung ist und das was ich
lese und höre dass dieses ziel
unverändert ist trotz erheblicher
verluste trotz logistischer probleme
trotz nicht geringer probleme im
kommunikationssystem und wie ich in den
letzten tagen mehrfach gesagt habe es
gibt zentrale politische strategische
punkte dazu gehört leider auch
beispielsweise die hafenstadt odessa und
wenn man sich dort die kräfte anschaut
die russland bereits vor der küste hat
im hafen harz am land hat dann gehe ich
beispielsweise davon aus dass das eines
der nächsten kommenden ziele der
russischen streitkräfte sein wird herr
jäger ganz egal was jetzt in den
nächsten tagen passieren wird wenn jetzt
russland nicht noch man muss ja aus
heutiger sicht fast sagen
unerwarteterweise einen militärischen
sieg davonträgt
scheitern das wird sich putin auch kaum
eingestehen jedenfalls nicht nach außen
nein das würde seine innere machtbasis
unterhöhlen der hut und wichtiges
problem er hat einen fehler gemacht und
dieser fehler rächt sich jetzt weil er
all die strategischen ziele die ja mit
dem krieg erreichen wollte jetzt schon
nicht mehr erreichen kann sind alle weg
es wird in der ukraine war wie immer der
krieg ausgeht keine russland freundliche
regierung geben die legitimität von
innen und außen hat es wird diesen
gürtel an puffer staaten in osteuropa
nicht geben und die vereinigten staaten
sind stärker in europa derzeit engagiert
als sie das alles erreichen kann die ja
im krieg erreichen will das muss man
abwarten hier geht es darum die
streitkräfte der ukraine zu schlagen und
die regierung zu verjagen und ob ihm das
noch gelingt ob es in den nächsten
wochen möglicherweise frische kräfte
gibt von denen ja immer wieder die rede
ist die leute angriffswirbel starten
können das müssen wir einfach abwarten
die zeichen die man momentan sehen kann
bei all dem was unabhängige quellen
hergeben sind so disparat dass man
wirklich nicht weiß und genau sagen kann
was wo in den nächsten tagen und wochen
geschehen wird dann im schnitt jetzt ist
ja die überlegung von stratege von
strategen auch dass wenn er jetzt
sozusagen feststeckt mit den bisherigen
methoden nicht weiter kommt also eine
art befreiungsschlag von putin gibt in
dem er vielleicht doch
massenvernichtungswaffen einsetzt
glauben sie dass er da zum äußersten
greifen wird um die ukraine doch noch
militärisch zu besiegen ich hoffe nicht
dass das glaube ich auch nicht weil das
hätte ja auch
verheerende folgen für ihn und für
russland womöglich
und ich glaube würde er einen anderen
ausweg suchen vielleicht eine
diplomatische lösung zu sagen zb also
diese tombers region wird jetzt
unabhängig und wir behalten die creme
und und man versucht hier irgendwie
einen ausweg zu finden
würde ihnen das zufriedenstellen er hat
ja ist er mit einem ganz anderen
anspruch gestaltet ja natürlich aber
wenn er vor diesen scherbenhaufen steht
vor dem er jetzt sitzt dann muss er halt
sich etwas anderes überlegen und ich
kann es aber nicht wir und ich mir vom
einsatz das glaube ich das sehe ich
nicht ich glaube nicht dass er verrückt
ist das glaube ich nicht er hat ja auch
enkelkinder und kinder also ich habe
nicht mehr spielen diese überlegung frau
papst aber in der nato eine rolle der
generalsekretär jens stoltenberg hat der
rhodia darauf reagiert er hat ja gesagt
wenn das passieren sollte also hat sich
jetzt glaube ich vor allem auf den
chemiewaffen einsatz den von den
massenvernichtungswaffen
wahrscheinlichsten einsatz bezogen dann
kündigt er härteste reaktion an welche
wären das
also zunächst einmal vielleicht nochmals
einen augenblick zurück zu der frage wie
wahrscheinlich ist das also ich würde
vorschlagen man verlässt sich da
vielleicht ein stück weit auch auf
unsere
eigene und bündnis interne aufklärung
die solche szenarien jetzt ja nicht zur
abschreckung oder als teil einer
strategischen message in die welt setzt
sondern weil es plausible indikatoren
dafür gibt und ich nehme also diese
warnungen durchaus ernst auch unsere
amerikanischen freunde aus dem
jeweiligen
geheimdiensten haben ja in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten gezeigt
dass ihre warnungen nicht aus der luft
gegriffen waren also dass nur so
grundsätzlich mal und zweitens die die
nato wird natürlich über mögliche
reaktionen nicht im vorfeld sprechen wir
müssen uns als allianz vorbehalten hat
putin zumindest zum teil im dunkeln zu
lassen ein bisschen raten zu lassen was
denn unsere aktion wer die eigentliche
botschaft so wie ich sie sehe ist dass
wir darauf reagieren werden als bündnis
und zweitens dass hier die ukrainischen
streitkräfte und unsere eigenen
streitkräfte auch
vorbereiten mit den sieben kids das sind
also unter das sind maßnahmen
ausrüstungsteile das sind medizinische
instrumente das sind auch nachsorge
instrumente also das ist schon sehr
konkret was hier jetzt ländern also
letztendlich an die ukraine gehen wird
und an unsere eigenen streitkräfte aus
der farbe gibt es eigentlich eine rote
linie und zwar jenseits eines angriffs
russlands auf ein nato dann ist klar
dann tritt der verteidigungsfall ein
gibt es aber trotzdem auch jenseits
dieses angriffs eine rote linie also
stichwort einsatz von
massenvernichtungswaffen mit
zehntausenden von toten zivilisten
der der nato zumindestens die
überlegungen ab bringt ob man nicht doch
eingreifen muss in welcher weise auch
immer oder ist diese wurde linie
tatsächlich der angriff auf nato gebiet
das ist ein graubereich und das ist teil
der eskalation möglichkeiten in diesem
konflikt meine analyse ist dass russland
nach wie vor die eskalation fähigkeit
hat es tut sich jetzt schwerer als
vermutlich erwartet wie frau bartz
gesagt hat wobei ich nicht weiß was
erwartet wurde ich kann mir auch nicht
wirklich vorstellen dass die russische
militär strategen nicht mit ukrainischen
widerstand gerechnet haben aber das ist
spekulation jedenfalls läuft es nicht so
das ist jetzt ein schneller sturz der
ukrainische regierung ist aber die
russen haben nach wie vor davon bin ich
überzeugt die eskalation fähigkeit und
sie sind skrupellos genug die auch
auszuspielen und das oberste ende ist
gewissermaßen eine nukleare eskalation
das wäre der supergau den wir um jeden
preis verhindern müssen darunter gibt es
aber auch noch eine ganze menge an
eskalation szenarien die auch die gefahr
haben sich gegenseitig hochschaukeln und
zum beispiel die frage wenn man jetzt
wirklich mit waffenlieferungen als nato
in diesem konflikt reingeht und man ist
ja schon drin die den russen wirklich
weh tun dann wäre es aus russischer
perspektive doch geradezu fahrlässig
wenn man das nicht auch als
angriffsziele definiert das heißt die
gefahr dass man immer weiter in diesem
sumpf gewissermaßen als nato
ohne dass man es eigentlich will
reingezogen wird die ist relativ groß
und das eskalationspotenzial einsatz
noch ist eben auch riesig das ist
wirklich die gefährlichste krise seit 80
jahren in europa und wahrscheinlich auch
in der internationalen politik aber ein
unterschied ob ein waffentransport aus
dem westen auf polnischem gebiet
angegriffen wird oder auf ukrainisch
also dass die frage war ja ist diese ist
das dann so eine frage die
möglicherweise von der nato dann doch
anders beantwortet wird dann gut ist die
frage ob nach unseren regeln gespielt
wird die nato sagt jetzt wir wollen
nicht konfliktpartei seien in russischer
perspektive stellt sich das anders da
durch die massiven waffenlieferungen
auch durch die harten und härtesten
sanktionen des westens ist der westen
konfliktpartei und wir sollten das
unterscheiden und ich finde die
botschaft die von diesem gipfel
ausgegangen ist sehr richtig dass eben
alle sagen wir wollen und werden nicht
in einen krieg mit russland eintreten
und wir müssen eine situation vermeiden
wo es doch passiert das heißt wir müssen
stärker uns engagieren für politische
lösungen und da denke ich gehört auch
zur wahrheit dazu dass man auch druck
auf die ukraine ausüben muss auch wenn
das unpopulär ist dass sie einer
politischen lösung zustimmt die
vermutlich bedeutet dass man die eine
oder andere kröte schlucken wird aber es
zeichnet sich eigentlich klar ab wie
eine politische lösung aussehen könnte
nämlich eine neutralität der ukraine
eine sozusagen akzeptanz der krim aktion
und ein sonderstatus für den dom bass
das sind wahrscheinlich die minimalziele
der russen unter die kein freelancer
richtig verstanden habe in den letzten
tagen hat das ja im prinzip schon als
verhandlungsmasse angeboten nun da gibt
es sehr unterschiedliche signale heute
in der frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung
ist ein interview mit dem chef
unterhändler der ukraine da liest sich
das wieder ganz anders das heißt wenn
die ukraine der erwartung hat dass man
mit harten militärischen widerstand den
politischen preis gewissermassen erhöhen
kann dann wird der krieg auch in diese
richtung weitergehen und ich denke wir
sollten alle energien einen
waffenstillstand legen das muss jetzt
das gebot der stunde sein jäger noch mal
ganz kurz zum möglichen einsatz von
atomwaffen dimitri mit jedes der frühere
russische präsident sondern der zweite
mann hinter
wladimir putin der hat ja damit ganz
offen gedroht
jetzt sagen ich glaube es war ein us
generäle gewesen die sagen dass ein
anderes sagen
die haben auch nicht geprüft beim
einmarsch in die ukraine ist das eine
logische konsequenz dass wir die das
ankündigen dass es dann tatsächlich auch
machen oder bleibt es bei der beiden
blöcke
dass das weiß man so schwierig das ist
eben nachher
das kann man im vorhinein nicht wissen
und wir wissen ja auch jetzt noch nicht
wann genau die entscheidung zum
einmarsch in die ukraine wirklich
gefallen ist wann sie umgesetzt wurde
wissen wir aber selbstverständlich
behalten sich die parteien alle
möglichkeiten offen man muss ja sehen
dass dieser krieg und krieg ist er in
einen großen konflikt eingebettet ist
der sozusagen von den häuserkämpfen in
mariupol reicht bis zu den strategischen
überlegungen in peking wie man am besten
davon profitiert und über alle möglichen
ebenen hinweg kalkulieren jetzt ganz
unterschiedliche akteure was sie hierfür
nutzen daraus ziehen können welche
vorteile sie haben können und die zwei
parteien die jetzt am stärksten
miteinander hier verbunden sind eben
russland und die ukraine
die spielen zumindest auf zwei ebenen
nämlich auf einmal im kriegsgeschehen
selbst wo jeder seine vorteile sucht und
vor allem kalkulieren muss ob er denn in
zukunft eine bessere position haben
könnte als er sie jetzt hat und das hat
auswirkungen auf die
verhandlungsbereitschaft erfahrung hat
das völlig zu recht gesagt da gibt es so
ein paar punkte die sich abgezeichnet
haben aber was ist immer ein hin und her
kennt wen man hört wer aus welcher
delegation gerade was sagt dann wird die
entnazifizierung rausgenommen wieder
eingenommen dann sind territoriale
zugeständnisse möglich dann sind sie
wieder nicht möglich da verhalten
natürlich diejenigen die das geschäft
hier betreiben alle bälle in der luft
weil sie hoffen am ende ein möglichst
vorteilhaft das ergebnis zu erzielen und
da gehört eben auch hinein diese drohung
von medwedew der sich ja jetzt schon ein
paar mal so als kettenhund verbaler
ketten und hier gezeigt hat in diesen
ganzen diskussionen der angst und
schrecken verbreiten will nicht nur in
der ukraine sondern auch bei uns so das
kommt ja auch an dieses ständige reden
über nuclear war das verbreitete keine
angst das ist ja unwahrscheinlich
irgendwas müsste eigentlich passieren
dass russland atomwaffen einsetzt es
gibt zwei möglichkeiten erster oder
zweiter schlag also die reaktion auf den
ersten schlag was müsste passieren dass
russland atomwaffen einsetzt oder ist es
theoretisch ist natürlich eine
theoretische frage ich glaube wenn wenn
russland also wenn das land von der nato
angegriffen werden würde dann würden sie
vielleicht
atomwaffen einsetzen
ich glaube man darf nicht vergessen dass
wir hier sehr bequem in berlin sitzen
und nicht in der ukraine und das ist ja
sehr einfach zu sagen dass die ukraine
bereit sein sollen irgendwelche kröten
zu schlucken sie haben schon einige
kröten geschluckt in den in den letzten
wochen man braucht nur nach maria porter
schauen die haben diesen krieg nicht
angefangen
die punkte die als verhandlungsbasis auf
dem tisch liegen sind ja die gleichen
seit wochen ja ob es die grammys die
sanktionen gegen russland und so weiter
und so fort das wird natürlich die basis
sein aber das hängt ja von den russen ab
und das wird ja von putin abhängen und
die glaubt diese ganzen diskussion ob es
atomwaffen müssen wie waffen auch wenn
die amerikaner jetzt sagen ja also
überlegt sich das damit wird er den
krieg nicht gewinnen es sei denn er
bereit ist die flächendeckend
einzusetzen
also er hat ja keine allzu guten
optionen gerade wenn man die berichte
liest und im fernsehen sieht über die
die russischen soldaten die die aufgeben
und wie schlägt die stimmung ist ihm her
also die die ukraine werden nicht
aufgeben und wenn er es einen solchen
schritt setzt wie chemiewaffen dann wird
der widerstand um so stärker sein
frau babs es hat ja
reaktion gegeben auf diese sogenannte
nukleare option auch man hat sich jetzt
sogar überlegt ob nicht die europäische
union sich selbst nuklear bewaffnen muss
also selbst eine nuklearmacht wird wir
haben ja zwei länder innerhalb europas
eines in der eu frankreich und dazu noch
großbritannien die atomar bewaffnet sind
ist das eine denkbare möglichkeit bei
einer fortschreitenden politischen und
militärischen integration in europa das
europa sagt bei dieser gefahr die uns
droht und wer weiß was da eines tages
möglicherweise auch nach putin noch
alles kommt müssen wir auch uns
nuklearwaffen auch weil wir vielleicht
nicht immer darauf hoffen können dass
die amerikaner zur stelle sind wenn es
in europa brennt
die ja die frage einer möglichen
europäischen
nuklearen bewaffnung ist sehr sehr viel
älter als dieser russische angriffskrieg
der sie wird eigentlich schon seit
einigen jahren zumindest in politischen
diplomatischen und in fachkreisen immer
mal wieder geführt und endete ein
bisschen bis dato zumindest wenn ich das
sagen darf im nirvana land weil unsere
französischen kollegen immer deutlich
gemacht haben dass sie
letztendlich nicht bereit wären
grundsätzliche veränderungen zu
überlegen die den eigenen sehr souverän
also nationalstaatlichen einsatz und die
kontrolle ihrer forste fragt betreffen
also ihrer nuklearen streitkräfte
interessanterweise jetzt auch im
zusammenhang mit dem strategischen
kompass der europäischen union der vor
wenigen tagen verabschiedet worden ist
sind die diskussion jetzt auch ein
bisschen wieder darüber entflammt würde
sich frankreich die sich ja dass ich ja
sehr stark auch eine größere
strategische autonomie eine größere
handlungsfähigkeit für die europäer
wünscht würden die bereit seien
eventuell von ihrer ursprünglichen
position
abzuweichen und
anfangen mit den interessierten partnern
darüber nachzudenken
fragezeichen also das muss man jetzt
abwarten aber es gibt bei der ganzen
diskussion noch einen punkt und das sind
unsere britischen verbündeten die wie
sie zurecht gesagt haben ja auch über
nukleare fähigkeiten verfügen und ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass eine
europäische irgendwie geartete variante
ein europäischer nuklearer schutzschirm
in irgendeiner weise ohne die
beteiligung grossbritanniens organisiert
werden könnte und schlussendlich auch
sollte und da sind wir natürlich noch
ein ganzes stück von entfernt weil die
europäische union ja noch nicht mal ein
irgendwie geartetes
abkommen mit dem post braig cit
großbritannien hat um über sicherheits-
und verteidigungspolitische fragen
insbesondere in dieser art auch reden zu
können
herr professor jäger es gibt ja eine
begriff oder ein wunsch der immer wieder
geäußert wird ständig auf wiedervorlage
eigentlich ist nämlich flugverbotszone
als eine kontrolle der ukraine um
luftangriffe vor allen dingen auf
wehrlose zivilisten zu verhindern das
wäre würde die nato das machen ja quasi
ein kriegsgrund oder ein kriegseintritt
aber es gibt ja noch die uno die ja auch
friedens erhalten oder frieden
schaffende maßnahmen verfügen kann wäre
das eine möglichkeit ist das denkbar
eine flugverbotszone die seeländer jeden
tag fordert unter unter uno mandat zu
verabschieden und durchzuführen
wenn man kann ja die resolution mal in
den sicherheitsrat der vereinten
nationen einbringen und dann wird sie
ein veto erfahren nein es ist keine
option das ist ja das problem dass ihr
eine der kriegsparteien eben über ein
veto im sicherheitsrat verfügt und
deswegen die uno als einweg er diesen
konflikt zu zu stärker zu sedieren
wenigstens ausgeschaltet ist das heißt
das würde auch gegen den vorschlag des
stellvertretenden polnischen
ministerpräsidenten kaczynski
sprechender ja gesagt hat wir schicken
eine friedenstruppe allerdings bewaffnet
in die ukraine auch dass selbst unter
uno mandat ist eher undenkbar
beziehungsweise also dass hier aktiv
eingegriffen werden kann um die
kriegsparteien in der ukraine
auseinanderzuhalten nein das halte ich
für keine realistische szenario
kaczynski will die nato in den krieg
ziehen es ist die ganz eindeutige
strategie ich kann nur davor warnen und
natürlich hört sich das harmlos an
flugverbotszone oder zusagen
un-friedenstruppe aber das wäre eine
militärische involvierung in diesem
konflikt der nur dazu führen würde dass
das gegen russland denkbar ist und dann
ist man im krieg mit russland wie man es
dreht und wendet das wäre keine gute
idee das wird auch den menschen in der
ukraine nicht helfen und wir sollten
diese dinge gewissermaßen nicht mit
heißem herzen sondern mit kühlen kopf
betreiben und zu ende denken was
passieren würde und wenn man das zu ende
denkt dann muss das gebot der stunde
heißen deeskalation und politische
lösung und keine weitere militärische
eskalation zumal alle klar gesagt haben
die ukraine ist kein bündnisfall und so
wird es auch bleiben hoffe ich
jedenfalls der druck gleichwohl in der
öffentlichkeit der steigt natürlich und
die stimmen mehren sich zum beispiel tom
enders der präsident der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik also
kein niemand der so etwas fördert
fordert und ich glaube wir sollten jetzt
auf allen ebenen dagegenhalten und
einfach nüchtern sagen das wäre ein
kriegseintritt der mit unkalkulierbaren
eskalation risiken verbunden wäre und
ihr aufhört kann nicht schmeckt das
polen und die baltischen länder aus im
wahrsten sinne des wortes nahe liegenden
gründen ja sich eigentlich eine
robustere nato wünschen was ist da
eigentlich die absicht etwas was würden
sie verstehen nicht nur
waffenlieferungen nicht nur mehr präsenz
das ist ja jetzt geplant da gibt es ja
einen richtigen aufwuchs von
nato-truppen in verschiedenen
mittelosteuropäischen ländern
würden diese länder noch gerne mehr
haben wird wenn man darüber hinausgehen
zumal wenn das weiter eskaliert sie ja
die ersten opfer eines krieges mit oder
gegen russland wären also das verlangen
die in wahrheit schon seit seit jahren
weil die die nicht die einzigen aber
unter den ländern waren
die das schon sehr früh erkannt haben
welche gefahr putin für sie darstellt
darunter verstehe ich zum beispiel
permanente basen der der nato
das war bislang nicht möglich weil es
ein abkommen gibt zwischen der nato und
russland aus dem jahr
1979 wo vereinbart worden ist dass man
das ja nicht tut ich glaube das ist ja
alles makulatur also seit diesem
einmarsch also solche überlegungen gibt
es jetzt schon und wenn präsident biden
wir heute gesagt hat breit ist die
truppenstärke der amerikaner zu
verdoppeln zum beispiel deutet schon
darauf hin dass wir solche schritte und
den kommenden jahren sehen werden das
wird aber auch für für deutschland
bedeuten dass man wesentlich mehr und
vielleicht nicht nur diese 100
milliarden für verteidigung ausgeben
wird müssen in enden in den nächsten
vier jahren wählte sind wirklich also
längerfristige planungen die schon
gewisse opfer gerade von von deutschland
erfordern wird es in deutschland klar
der politik und auch den menschen hier
in deutschland dass es nicht nur um
erhöhten finanziellen einsatz geht
sondern dass entspannungs politik
verständigung eine richtige
friedensordnung ganz ganz so weit weg
ist ich hab heute irgendwo gelegt
manchmal ich glaube dass
die jahrzehnte glaube ich könnte es
dauern diese bis es wieder in einen
zustand hat wie wir ihn nach 1990 hatten
ist das den deutschen ich glaube das ist
den deutschen klar aber es ist den
deutschen überhaupt nicht klar und da
sieht man wie sehr eine strategische
kultur in dem in dem land fehlt die gibt
es ja ganz einfach nicht im gegensatz zu
frankreich oder großbritannien
bis vor kurzem hat man ja noch über die
strategische autonomie gesprochen bis
vor ein paar wochen und da war mal
jahrelang nicht bereit diese zwei
prozent marke der nato zu erfüllen und
jetzt auf einmal dieses sogenannte
zeitenwende ich weiß nicht wie
glaubwürdig das ist also angesichts der
diskussionen der letzten jahre und
angesichts der tatsache dass die
politiker die jetzt an der macht sind
diejenigen waren die sich dagegen
gestimmt haben also ich bin sehr
gespannt wie sich wie sich das weiter
entwickelt ein militär kann man nicht
von heute auf morgen aufbauen die
bundeswehr kann man nicht von heute auf
morgen
attraktiver machen für die bevölkerung
und die ist jetzt der so nicht besonders
attraktiv leider und das sind dinge die
man sich wirklich lange überlegen muss
also oder schnell überlegen muss wie man
das alles ändert weil die vereinigten
staaten werden
nicht allzu lange auf deutschland warten
und der druck wird steigen und der
nächste präsident
nach beiden auch wenn er die die die
nächste wahl gewinnt wird wird
eigentlich nicht so kulant sein mit dem
deutschen also davon gehe ich aus herr
jäger als überbrückungsmaßnahme wäre es
ja dann denkbar dass deutschland einen
crashkurs in realitätswahrnehmung macht
ja das sind wir ja gerade bei die große
frage ist ob das anhält momentan ist das
so weil die kriegsgräuel es jeden tag
wieder ins bewusstsein rufen das ist der
grund weshalb der bundeskanzler so etwas
sagen konnte und ihm nicht die partei
sofort reingegrätscht ist in jedem
anderen moment wäre das die größte
politische blutgrätsche aller zeiten
gewesen die ihr erfahren hätte und es
ist völlig richtig das grundproblem ist
jetzt wird es diese diskussion über die
zeit verlängert wird die man von diesem
krieg sozusagen täglich gefangen
gehalten wird nämlich über die jahre
hinweg die es gilt eine strategische
kultur aufzubauen
französische präsident hat in seiner
seiner rede gesagt auch da gibt es dann
irgendwie ein wunder und auf einmal ist
in europa dar und die ist eben nicht da
das ist ein jahrelanges defizit das wir
hier insbesondere in deutschland haben
und wenn wir das nicht beheben das auch
nicht möglich sein die ganzen maßnahmen
die sicherheitspolitisch notwendig sind
zu legitimieren und dafür zustimmung zu
finden und wenn es jetzt eben und der
krieg in der ukraine ist dann wissen wir
nicht was es in zwei drei jahren im
süden europas ist oder im westen
sicherheits gefahren lauern ja eine
ganze reihe und ist man darf sich nicht
nur auf den einen fall konzentrieren
sondern muss ein gesamtkonzept machen an
bedrohungsanalysen für die europäische
union um das bewusstsein zu stärken dass
es eben alle bürger europas angeht wenn
europa bedroht ist wenn wir das
weiterhin so national machen dann
bleiben wir dabei dass wir von freunden
umgeben sind und uns überhaupt nicht
interessiert von wem unsere freunde
umgeben sind verpasste es braucht ja
auch diese strategische kultur diese neu
zu erwerbende kultur wenn diese präsenz
in osteuropa der nato-truppen von dauer
sein soll so wie sie jetzt angelegt ist
was da heute schon besprochen wird
worden ist und glaube ich auf dem
regulären nato gipfel in madrid im juni
dann endgültig verabschiedet wird ist
das strategisch so angelegt dass das
wirklich auf dauer gedacht ist oder
zunächst mal nur solange der ukraine
krieg andauert
also zunächst einmal
ich bin nicht der meinung dass wir das
hier das klang so ein bisschen bei den
kollegen an um ein vorübergehendes
phänomen dass wir das damit zu tun haben
nein es ist in der tat eine
einschneidende zäsur und ich glaube dass
ich kann da nur für mich sprechen
der
der die dimension dieser dieser
veränderung die sich da jetzt seit ein
paar wochen vor unseren augen
darstellt dass die noch nicht in allen
köpfen angekommen ist aber es ist völlig
deutlich
wir haben eine längere zeit des
geostrategischen umbruchs vor uns und es
gibt kein drehbuch es gibt kein
kurzes korrekt und es reichen auch nicht
nur ein paar kröten die man vielleicht
irgendwie schluckt wir haben wirklich
eine
fundamentale krise vor uns ergo muss man
in dieser krise kurzfristig agieren das
tut nato desto tu das tut die
internationale gemeinschaft immer wieder
jetzt in den letzten wochen wir brauchen
mittelfristig ist und wir brauchen
natürlich auch ein langfristiges konzept
oder eine langfristige strategie und
diese langfristige strategie kann sich
jetzt nicht nur auf
russland fokussieren sondern sie muss
auch im blick haben dass es auf dieser
welt noch eine zweite continental macht
geht gibt die die russland leider immer
noch unterstützt nicht nur verbal und
politisch sondern auch mit einer ganz
ausgeprägten partnerschaft nämlich china
und beide continental mächte stehen in
einer fundamentalen opposition zu
unserer liberal demokratischen ordnung
und zwar in jedem einzelnen politikfeld
in der wirtschaft was die unsere
meinungsfreiheit angeht was unsere
rechte an gehen alles und darauf müssen
wir uns einstellen und das kann man
nicht mit ein paar klugen würde ich mal
sagen kurzen sätzen und auch nicht mit
einer kurzen rede sondern darüber muss
jetzt wirklich intensiv mit unseren
partnern im bündnis in der eu und auch
mit anderen demokratischen staaten auf
dieser welt nachgedacht werden allzu
viel zeit haben wir nicht weil die
menschen in der ukraine
jeden tag weiter leiden weiter
zerstörungen und und tod erfahren und
das ist nicht nur eine akademische
betrachtung sondern das ist für sie eine
ganz ganz nah zutiefst menschliche
erfahrungen die sie jetzt machen müssen
das ist gerade gesagt hat ist also eine
art kroatischer knoten wenn jetzt china
da noch kommt ist das ja noch
komplizierter und eigentlich ja noch
schwerer zu lösen
wie was muss da jetzt passieren wie kann
man den durchschlagen oder ist das
einfach ein hinweis darauf dass wir noch
ganz lange mit diesem problem zu tun
haben und ich glaube da muss man
wirklich drei ebenen auseinanderhalten
die eine ist die ebene der ukraine das
ist jetzt der heiße krieg der eingedämmt
werden muss die zweite ebene ist dass
die nato als bündnis ihre
verteidigungsfähigkeit dauerhaft erhöhen
muss das was wir im kalten krieg
containment also eindämmung russischer
macht genannt haben das ist jetzt zu
recht wieder auf der tagesordnung die
dritte ebene die frau war angesprochen
hat ist genauso wichtig wir sind dabei
in eine auseinandersetzung zwischen
autokratien und demokratischen systemen
in der internationalen politik zu
geraten und da ist china und russland
wahrscheinlich auf der einen seite und
ein paar andere und der westen auf der
anderen seite und wir müssen darüber
nachdenken wie wir aus diesem konflikt
wieder rauskommen das heißt wir dürfen
dann nicht nur auf eigene stärke und
militär und militarisierung setzen das
ist ein wichtiger baustein ja aber wir
müssen auch und auf unsere eigenen
interessen gucken und nicht nur eine
werte geladen außenpolitik machen und
dieser spagat zwischen interessen und
werten das müssen wir noch sehr hart zu
ende diskutieren glaube ich er
freiwillig hatte ja vorhin gesagt durch
die waffenlieferung des westens sind wir
so was schon wie ein erhalte
kriegspartei jetzt ist ja auch
beschlossen worden die waffenlieferungen
werden verstärkt abwehrwaffen die
offenbar sehr wirksam sind gegen
russische flugzeuge und vor allem gegen
große panzer jetzt soll es auch anti
schiffs raketen geben da ist eine
riesige armada an der schwarzmeerküste
aufgefahren um auch von see her die
ukraine zu bedrohen ist das eine
möglichkeit diesen krieg in absehbarer
zeit zu beenden oder ist sind diese
verstärkung waffenlieferungen eher ein
hinweis dass es noch sehr viel länger
sehr viel blutiger und kriegerischer
weitergeht ich gehe davon aus
dass ich ein bisschen widersprechen ich
halte das schon für für notwendig um
unsere glaubwürdigkeit als westen zu
bewahren die ukraine können wir nicht
ganz einfach im stich lassen und
die ganzen werte die wir immer als
westen hochhalten denn dann würden wir
ja verraten also wenn wir wenn wir
der ukraine nicht helfen würden also ich
glaube das wird auf jeden fall
weitergehen das muss weitergehen und
wir sind nicht direkt kriegspartei aber
das ist ja völlig gleich meine im
zweiten weltkrieg hat die schweiz ja
auch waffen geliefert dann beide seiten
so weit ich weiß also
gibt es ja schon präzedenzfälle für
waffenlieferungen also sind natürlich
ein bisschen anders jetzt sind jetzt
fast am ende der sendung
professor jäger man kann sich im moment
ja kaum vorstellen dass es mal
verhandlungen und eine irgendwie auch
immer geartete zusammenarbeit mit
russland geben kann in der zukunft haben
sie da eine vorstellung wie die aussehen
könnte man kann er sich zwei szenarien
vorstellen eine mit putin und eine ohne
putin wie muss man sich das vorstellen
nicht nur wann das passieren wird
sondern gibt es in absehbarer zeit eine
chance mit russland wieder ins gespräch
zu kommen trotz all der bilder die ja im
kopf haften bleiben aus mario pohl aus
katies und aus kiew
das ist ein richtiges problem was auch
die öffentliche meinung angeht denn die
empörung ist groß und es der aldi
untersuchungen die jetzt über
kriegsverbrechen eingeleitet werden die
treffen natürlich auch auf die stimmung
auf eine wahrnehmung dass genau das hier
geschehen ist jenseits aller
juristischen aufarbeitung und solch
einer stimmung muss man aber dann ganz
nüchtern sagen dass das gespräch mit den
repräsentanten russlands da zu suchen
ist wo russland
notwendig ist wo man das land ignorieren
kann kann man auch repräsentanten
ignorieren die man eben nicht treffen
will das machen staaten ja nun auch aber
immer dann wenn das gespräch gesucht
werden muss können wir uns nicht
aussuchen wer der repräsentant russlands
ist und das führt zu problemen
spätestens im november in indonesien
wenn der g20-gipfel ist und der
präsident russlands immer noch putin
heißt und er dann
corona angst hin oder her dort anderer
ist spätestens dann wird die frage
anstehen wie sich die westlichen staaten
hier verhalten und da gibt es ja auch
nur eine ganze reihe von beispielen sei
es das apartheid südafrika und andere
die man versucht hat aus zu grants am
ende muss man den dialog führen und die
isolation von staaten in der
internationalen politik ist ein hoch
kommunikativer prozesse
häufig hinter den türen aber überall da
muss öffentlich ist es eben für die
öffentliche meinung schwer auszuhalten
gut das sind also viele fragen und wenig
befriedigende antworten die ich bedanke
mich bei stefanie babst bei thomas jäger
bei matthew karnitschnig und bei
johannes farbig liebe zuschauer am
sonntag ist landtagswahl im saarland und
die phoenix war sendung beginnt um 17
uhr moderiert von eva genau so viel zu
einem wichtigen programmhinweis am
wochenende jetzt folgt phoenix der tag
mit thomas bade mit aktuellen zum nato
und zum eu gipfel der eu gipfel ist ja
immer noch im gange die sitzung der
staats und regierungschefs dauerten
findet ihr auch morgen erst ihr ende
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]